si la policía le acusa de un intento de
asesinato y otro de agresión ambos en
segundo grado el joven se encuentra
detenido y sin fianza se trata como
decíamos de un joven de 24 años que
reside en el estado vecino de nueva
yersey nacido aquí en eeuu y de padres
libaneses ahora mismo los investigadores
están registrando su casa la tienen
bloqueada en una investigación que
avanza de momento sabemos que actuó solo
y que tenía una entrada para el evento
literario en el que se produjo el ataque
también está en tela de juicio la
seguridad que había en ese evento al
parecer y según fuerte fuentes cercanas
a la seguridad del mismo aseguran que se
les pidió a la organización reforzar más
la seguridad pero no quisieron hacerlo
recordemos que para entrar al evento no
había controles de seguridad ni tampoco
detectores de metales el joven al
parecer es simpatizante del gobierno
iraní aunque de momento la policía no ha
confirmado cuál serían los motivos
y ataque mientras tanto el autor de 75
años el escritor se debate entre la vida
y la muerte conectado a un respirador
tras ser sometido a una operación ayer
dice su agente que de momento no puede
hablar que podría perder un ojo y que
tiene dañados un brazo y el hígado tras
recibir al menos dos puñaladas una en el
cuello y otra en el abdomen